who wants to know if you bought the Jets  today what would be the first thing you  would do  Lou I've always said that the first  thing I would do once I buy these New  York Jets I'm pointing to the stadium by  the way is I would start a program that  would send the jersey to every  six-year-old boy and girl in the New  York New Jersey tri-state area with a  handwritten note from me saying thank  you or maybe just a note that I would  sign some because that's a big number  but I want to basically convert every  single youth into the green not the blue  and so that would be the number one  thing I would do start the program that  I've been imagining and dreaming about  my whole life